Since 2014, a working group has been developing
proposals for the rehabilitation of the Kaiapoi River.
Today we are at the corner of Charles and
Smith Street upstream of the Williams Street Bridge.
So Neville tell me, what's happening with
this area of the river?
Well this is where the corner many years ago
was realigned and it needs
to be meandered a bit more.
So the channel will be dug out from up at
the Mafekin area. and come through here with
the main channel.
And then batter of this corner you can see
behind us here, that will get battered off.
And if these plantings that we have planted
as a trial all work and they all do what they
are supposed to do and grow, then that whole
area will go into the river with the plantings
to make sure that we: 1) Stabilise the bank,
but 2) That we can also help with purifying
water and things like that when we plant them.
Putting all the plants back in here and making
sure that we have plantings that overhang
banks, meandering banks.
Great collection point for eggs, for all species,
invertebrates, in which to play and make sure
that they breed in a proper manner and natural
manner within the river itself.
So Neville, you mentioned sloping the bank
across the river here, what do you mean by that?
Well what it should do is create a much better
flow, a much more even flow.
At the moment it comes around corner really
rapidly, causes erosion to the bank, the inner
bank here and that should just slow that a
little and stop some of the big eddies that
come around the corner.
And just make a more consistent flow through
the river and a more naturalised bank on the other side.
So how can people have their say?
Well, right here they can come in and there
will be an open day at Ruataniwha and people
can have their input that way.
We have the website, we have councillors,
community board members and we really want
people to have their input.
There are six proposals we'd like your feedback
on, attend our open day on the 27th of April
or find out more at waimakariri.govt.nz